s great to welcome to the program today.
Anna Muldoon, who is a former science policy
adviser at the Department of Health and Human
Services, currently a PHC student at Arizona
State University, studying infectious disease
and social crisis.
So great to talk to you today.
Hi, David.
Good to talk to you.
So I recently read an article by a Turkish
author, I actually forget their name, but
it talked about some of the social similarities
that have taken place as infectious disease
has spread in different times and in sort
of moderately recent human history.
That denial is often an initial reaction from
places outside the initial sort of perceived
source that scapegoating is very common, finding
some initial group or country or whatever.
Right now, there's a lot of talk of China.
Jews were blamed for the plague in times past,
et cetera, et cetera.
And also the idea sort of of the disease as
a personal failing, a human failing of some
kind, which can take some different forms.
Maybe we can start there.
Like what are the general trends that you
have studied and seen over time related to
infectious disease?
So you nailed a lot of them there, actually.
You know, diseases, a personal failing is
a really old conception and disease as punishment
is a really old concept.
We've had that embedded in particularly Western
Christian culture for a very, very long time.
Going all the way back to the Bible, plagues,
plagues and pharaoh, but also all through
European history as infectious disease appeared
and disappeared.
There were moments where it was viewed as
punishment from God for social sins, punishment
of the individual for individual sins.
And as we moved into a sort of more secular
moment that has transformed really in the
19th and 20th centuries in2 sort of individual
punishment for some behavioral failing, whatever
that might be.
So sometimes it is, you know, drinking or
partying too much cholera.
19TH century cholera was blamed on European
immigrants who were sort of a bit more lively
than their counterparts in New York City.
And then we're blamed for having cholera,
saying it was spread either by beer or occasionally
by communion wine.
That one was interesting.
And then sort of as infectious disease has
spread this time, we've seen a lot of people
talking about New Orleans and, you know, Mardi
Gras being the spot that spread it through
New Orleans because those people needed to
party, which is not really totally fair to
New Orleans.
And it's it's still very present.
I think in the ways that we talk about covered
and the ways that we have talked about disease
spread now and really for the past several
thousand years.
Unfortunately, the idea not just of the disease
as punishment for sin, but of prayer, maybe
as a protector.
How far back does that go?
I mean, we recently saw this video of a woman
leaving a megachurch where she said she's
covered in the blood of Jesus.
So she's fine and so on and so forth, that
I'm guessing that's also not new.
Nope.
Also not new.
Very much not new.
It's.
What's interesting is that the ways that that
worked kind of pre reformation are a little
bit different.
And it was more kind of a prayer covering
the whole community, but also a sort of acceptance
that disease was part of life now.
And in particular, in the United States, there
have been fights about national prayer to
combat epidemics all the way back to the 18th
century.
Right.
In 1721, there was a large smallpox outbreak
in Boston.
And there are fights about prayer and predestination
as they begin to introduce inoculation.
And whether you should simply pray that you
survive, because if you're a good person,
you'll survive or whether you should take
this inoculation, which at that moment was
viewed as possibly, you know, violating predestination
by messing with the plan.
And then in the eighteen thirties and eighteen
fifties, with cholera on the east coast of
the United States, there are some impressively
intense fights about national prayer to prevent
the epidemic that in some cases actually threatened
to unseat a variety of politicians and turn
into political issues as well as religious
issues.
So that one's old and very embedded in American
culture.
So for me, this is a part of, at least right
now, seeing the current administration's handling
of the virus, at least over the last month,
really as a culture war rather than a medical
war.
And I did a segment about this earlier this
week.
My perspective is that they've essentially
failed on the medical war.
So they're making it about culture and values,
which are much more pliable in terms of empirically
determining what it is that's going on.
And so masks have become a signal of your
perspective as to what's going on.
Open versus closed has become an issue of
government tyranny and so on and so forth.
Is this the way this often goes where it becomes
a culture war?
Mm hmm.
You know, honestly, having studied a lot of
disease history, I would say that this kind
of polarization of responding to disease is
fairly unusual.
The fights.
So the fights around infectious disease do
often fall on cultural lines.
Right.
So there's there's an author I love called
Deserto who talks about the ways that in that
in certain moments, the things that underlie
society, the tensions that are already there,
kind of break apart and come to light.
He talks about these tensions that exist that
we all live inside, sort of rising up from
under the streets.
It's a beautiful passage, but I think.
The commonality among infectious disease outbreaks
is that they intensify and make very visible
social decision, social divisions, social
tensions and existing problems.
But rarely do you see this kind of.
Pretending that a disease just doesn't exist
in communities where it does.
It's I obviously am studying this as I'm working
on it because it's both fascinating and a
little disturbing, too.
To what do you attribute it?
I mean, why why?
It seems too simplistic to say.
Well, it's because of Trump.
I mean, he seems to be the one who is at the
top of the federal government right now.
But there's some element of society allowing
that to take place as well.
Right.
Absolutely.
I think that America for a long time has been
deeply divided along urban and rural lines.
And that has very much played out and covered
where the early outbreaks were very much in
urban areas where people travel more.
And it's only now that they're really moving
into rural areas.
So for a long time, the pattern of kov it
in the country actually exemplified that division.
I think that America has for a long time had
some intense class division among types of
workers.
And that is also very much playing out here
where a lot of the a lot of workers simply
can't stay home.
And so for those who can, responding to the
disease is a different type of ask.
Right.
Asking me to work from home on history, historical
stuff or policy is a very different ask than
asking that of someone who works in a factory
where working from home isn't an option.
So some of it, I think is also about.
The ways people have to justify their own
need to, you know, eat and continue working
and feed their families.
And then some of it is the intense polarization
that we've experienced over really the past
10 years.
I think that divisions and what news we watch,
what radio shows we listen to, what newspapers
we read have really made it possible for there
to be multiple worlds based on the same information
in a way that just hasn't historically always
been true when it comes to talking now about
stigma of of disease itself.
There's certain diseases that have more social
stigma attached to them.
So certainly sexually transmitted infections
and diseases would be one category within
cancer.
Lung cancer sometimes generates less sympathy
because it can be connected to the bad act
of smoking.
Cigarets, as an example.
Where does the where do these types of pandemics
that like Corona virus kind of fit into this
stigma analysis?
So I wish I wish dearly that I could tell
you that pandemic disease was an exemption
from stigma.
Unfortunately, I. I don't get to say that.
So it's.
Lower on the scale, then things like LCD or
lung cancer.
Higher on the scale than zero.
Right.
So you're starting to see problems where people
have recovered from Cauvin and are having
difficulty still getting ambulances to come
to their house or their neighbors don't want
them to leave the house or want them to move
out of the neighborhoods, businesses where
the owner has recovered, where no one will
go inside because they're afraid of the virus.
And I think that that is something we will
probably see expanding.
There has also, unfortunately, been a lot
of racialization of this virus that has cause
serious problems in a lot of Chinese American
communities, but also, unfortunately, other
Asian-American communities.
That isn't so much disease stigma as disease
blame and kind of racialization of the disease.
So I think that those are those are things
that we as a society and as a nation need
to consciously combat and pay attention to,
because I know someone that we're covered
from Kofod four months ago is not going to
give you the virus, but people are still afraid.
It seems I'm one of the ways where the stigma
is is entering a little more is with some
of the reports that, for example, of the younger
people that are dying overwhelmingly, they
are obese and obesity is often associated
with, you know, moral failings rather than
medical conditions.
So it seems maybe that's one way in which
it's creeping in lately.
Oh, yeah.
I actually started my first year and a half.
I was in public health.
I was doing research on obesity stigma, and
I found infectious disease to be a less depressing
topic.
And it tells you something about how bad it
is.
Yeah.
I think that absolutely.
A lot of the things about preexisting conditions
are allowing people to blame those who've
died of covered for their own deaths, which
is deeply frustrating.
You know, most of the most of the preexisting
conditions that really predispose people to
dying from Koven are those that are really
frequently linked to structural factors in
economics, in race and access to medical care
in location.
And so it is kind of quadruply frustrating
to then watch them become a way to write off
KOVA deaths because they're almost entirely
structurally linked.
Comorbidities, I guess, is the best way to
put it.
Yeah, no question about that.
And that's often missing from the science.
Science can tell us a lot of the facts, but
it doesn't.
It rarely tells us about the economic and
sociological factors that kind of led to those
being.
Being the facts.
We've been speaking with Anna Muldoon, who's
a former science policy adviser at the Department
of Health and Human Services.
Anna, so great to speak to you.
I really appreciate your time.